[Music]  from the core systems to the Outlands  Hammond robotics has been at the  forefront of progress revolutionising  and innovating the future our new  Hammond robotics is committed to leading  the Outlands into the future through  extraordinary breakthrough solutions in  colonial manufacturing transportation  security and now introducing our  advanced development in energy  production and distribution the Hammond  robotics planet harvester here at  Hammond robotics the people of the  Outlands are our number one priority  Hammond robotics we are here for you  you know dispatch needs  a game-changer  go and hide  another day another road I see you're  shaken recharged and ready for better  [Music]  detector  surprise  [Music]  [Music]